okay let's have some follow-up if I may
on this Trump [ __ ] story which we
are now saying because everybody's
allowed to say it now that Trump said it
how long can we say it for though years
oh yeah I'm planning on even if it's not
in the context of this story now I'm
going to be saying the word for a very
very long time
so the backstory is dick Durbin
Democratic senator was in the room with
Donald Trump along with many other
senators when Donald Trump reportedly
said that we don't want people coming to
the u.s. immigrating to the US from
[ __ ] countries instead we want
people coming to the u.s. from countries
like Norway dick Durbin was one of the
voices that said this is what Trump said
in the room Lindsey Graham hasn't
commented but he is quoted as during the
meeting using the word in quoting Trump
to say I think that you're wrong about
what you're saying about these [ __ ]
countries however Donald Trump pointed
to as I told you yesterday a couple of
Republican senators who said we don't
agree with the dick Durbin story Trump
didn't say it Trump just did not say
[ __ ] hole or he said [ __ ] house right
those were the defenses from these two
senators then and I played this clip for
you yesterday Donald Trump referenced
those two senators as proof he didn't do
it take a listen
so those are some of these communities
never made it harder to see what the
room said about my comments that weird
man
yeah so anyway the Senators Trump was
referring to did you see what those
other senators in the room said those
were senators Republican senators Tom
cotton and David Perdue they were the
ones saying Trump didn't say it or he
said [ __ ] house not [ __ ] they have
now been outed as straight-up lying if
they didn't know what Trump said their
story was we don't remember what Trump
said we didn't hear what Trump said we
don't know what Trump said and later
cotton and Purdue came out and said Oh
Trump said [ __ ] house countries not
[ __ ] countries this is sort of what
you call a lie by omission right if the
truth is that they didn't hear Trump's a
[ __ ] hole because he said [ __ ] house you
need to volunteer that upfront and
remember upfront what they said is we
didn't hear anything we don't we don't
know what was said and the only later
did they come out and say oh no what he
said was [ __ ] so we were right when
we said he didn't say [ __ ] we just
initially forgot to mention that we
actually knew exactly what he said and
it was this other word which is
different but without any real
distinction in terms of its meaning
that's like did you kill this woman
yesterday and you say no I didn't
because it happened at 12:01 a.m. right
if you're trying to get out of a murder
charge
you make the prosecution prove its case
if you're just trying to be an honorable
and honest elected official you don't
just say I didn't hear [ __ ] hole and
then leave it at that if you heard [ __ ]
house you immediately say it wasn't [ __ ]
hole it was [ __ ] house and they didn't
do that their initial story was we don't
know what he said and they really didn't
have to get caught in the lie for us to
know that it was alive because they were
saying I don't recall or I didn't hear
the president say that I mean anyone who
understands that legal least knows what
they're getting at it's possible that
they literally didn't hear it because
there were five conversations going on
at once right like it's remotely
possible but yes it was weird from the
beginning so headline one is cotton and
Purdue lied and then Trump used those
lies to smear dick Durbin as a liar but
the bigger picture thing that people
aren't talking about is that defending
Trump by saying oh he said [ __ ] house
and
[ __ ] it's not a great defense
because basically it's the same thing
right like for all we know Trump is so
stupid he was trying to say [ __ ] but
he didn't even know that that's what
you're supposed to say and he said [ __ ]
house instead but that's not really a
defense like the big exculpation of
Trump is it wasn't [ __ ] hole it was [ __ ]
house that doesn't really make any sense
right I was gonna explain the
distinction between the two things but
then I decided better off not to
honestly though is there one like it's
the same message right which is he
doesn't want people coming from
countries that he doesn't consider to be
countries we want people coming from oh
like Norway Norway is the example of a
good country but he doesn't want people
from [ __ ] or [ __ ] countries
okay the takeaway is the country is
being run by little kids effectively and
I don't even get why they're trying to
pretend anymore if we are only debating
over [ __ ] house versus [ __ ] what is
there even to debate right we know Trump
is a liar we know that his immediate
staffers are liars the only real
question now is why are these other
Republicans lying for Trump like why is
it that Tom cotton and David Perdue said
we are going to create a pretext that
Trump can point to to defend himself
from comments that are truly disgusting
and vile it's their character now that
is imputable because of these lies well
I think when it comes to Tom cotton he
has his eyes set on coming part of the
administration oh yeah there was a
double switch about Rex Tillerson
leaving as the Secretary of State and
they with Mike Pompeo in as Secretary
Secretary of State and so that would
create an opening at CIA director right
and maybe Tom cotton could take over
there so he has to suck up to trump if
he wants that position that is a really
cynical and probably accurate assessment
of what might be going on which
Republicans at this point aren't lying
for Trump if we started a list I mean I
guess James Comey got fired because he
wasn't willing to lie for trove he's a
Republican Lindsey Graham fact-checked
him in real time that's right Lindsey
Graham did a fact check Robert Moeller
is another Republican who so far isn't
lying for Trump on CNN Anna Navarro is a
Republican strategist I've not heard her
lying for Trump Joe Scarborough has been
a Republican and he hasn't been lying
for Trump although he quit being
Republican I believe he went to be an
independent now yeah there is a list of
Republicans not willing to live for
Trump but it's pretty small
if you glean nothing from this other
than these people lied what I want you
to take away from it is vote them out we
can get rid of these people the election
is under ten months away I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's episode of the David
Pakman show I am pleased to tell you is
made possible in part by brilliant which
is a fantastic and unique online service
that has sort of reinvented the way
people learn math and science if you
watch the David Pakman show
like me you're probably someone who's
curious about how the world works you
like to learn new things maybe you have
a casual interest in things like physics
or solar energy AI philosophy computer
science but you want to take it to the
next level whether you already have a
grasp on any of these subjects or you're
looking for a fun and engaging way to
become acquainted with these topics for
the first time brilliant really is the
place to go where you can actually learn
hands-on by solving problems and puzzles
puzzles that were designed by expert
educators and professionals you can get
started right now by signing up for free
at brilliant org slash David Pakman the
first 200 people who visit brilliant org
slash David Pakman will get 20% off an
annual Premium Membership one more time
that's brilliant org slash David Pakman